لهجه حاده لمسؤولين الروس موسكو ترد
بتهديد والتحذير على الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا
تهديدات لا يتردد مطلقوها في التلويح
بالخيار الاخضر
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين منذ بدايه
الحرب وضع قوه الرضع النووي في حاله تاهب
هدد مؤخرا برد نووي على بريطانيا في حال
زودت اوكرانيا بذخائر اليورانيم المنظم
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويكو اعتبرها
مقدمه لصدام نووي محتمل تلويح بالسلاح
النووي لم يتوقف نائب رئيس المجلس الامن
القومي الروسي
هدد بحرب نوويه اذا اعتقل رئيسه بوتين كما
لوح مدفيديف باستهداف مبنى المحكمه
الجنائيه في لاهاي بضربه صاروخيه الرجل
حدد ما قد يدفع روسيا الى الرضع النووي
اذا تحدثنا عن بعض الاشياء الجاده
المرتبطه بمحاوله استعاده شبه جزيره القرن
وما الى ذلك فقد تحدث عن هذا وكتبت عنه
فيما سبق من الواضح تماما ان هذه اسباب
لاستخدام جميع وسائل الدفاع بما في ذلك
عقيده الردع النووي
تهديدات من اجل التهديد ربما لكن كل
سيناريوهات التصعيد مطروحه ولعل اللجوء
الى سيناريوهات الرعب مرهونه بحسابات
الربح والخساره لدى بوتين